as a teacher thinking about using a tool
inside or outside of your classroom the
first natural question is well does that
tool work and that's also very important
to us here at Khan Academy with our
mission we don't want just people to use
it we want to feel good that that usage
is actually driving real learning and so
what I'm what I'm going to give an
overview of in this video is a very
large study conducted in the state of
Idaho it was across the entire state
understanding whether Khan Academy is
driving real learning and this is the
largest study that has ever been done on
a personalized learning tool and so I'm
going to summarize this will also give a
link to the study later on in this
tutorial it was done and funded in
conjunction with the J a and Catherine
Albertson Family Foundation and so I'm
just going to summarize the report here
so it just has a big picture let me go
right down here there's a lot of really
cool stories from teachers and and and
educators and district officials here
talking about how they implemented the
pilot but the big picture this was 47
schools 33 districts 173 teachers
several thousand students throughout the
state of throughout the state of Idaho
here and the what they did in the study
is the students took the nwea
map exam at the beginning of the year
they worked on Khan Academy and then
they took the nwea
map exam at the end of the year and the
way that efficacy was measured is well
the map exam can see for any student
whether they are a student who is more
advanced or a student who's remediating
they can see what their expected growth
is in a traditional model and then they
can compare that expected growth to what
the actual growth was using Khan Academy
and so let's just cut to the chase and
see what the results are and there's a
lot of videos that we have on our
educator portal that talks about how how
the different teachers used Khan Academy
and what they found valuable but I'll go
straight to the data here for the sake
of this video and so if we go down here
this is just the distribution of
students by grade level you can see
kind of late elementary and middle
schools were the bulk of the students in
the study were but even in third grade
we're talking about over 200 students so
this is a very large-scale study and
this first one says mission completion
versus spring percentile mission
completion these are the grade level
personalized learning experiences that
the students can pick so there is a
third grade mission there's actually
alert an early learning mission there's
a third fourth fifth there's all the way
up to algebra geometry trigonometry
there's even a calculus mission and
these are aligned to the important state
standards especially the Common Core
Standards for K through precalculus and
they are aligned to the AP standards for
calculus and so what you see here is
depending on how much a student
completed of their mission over the
course of the pilot it correlates very
strongly with how they performed on the
map exam during the spring assessment
now you might say well of course
naturally a student who completes more
is well that's maybe a student who's a
little bit more advanced and so they're
going to be in a higher percentile and I
would agree with you that makes sense so
this is this right here is not evidence
of or clear evidence of efficacy just
yet but you definitely want to see this
trend if for whatever reason this was a
flatline or if this was if it went if we
had a downward slope for some reason
well then then we would have an issue
but this is the direction that you want
to see but we want to see more evidence
we want to see for a given student
regardless of where they started that
usage of Khan Academy is not driving
just expected learning for all we know
this might be just what you would expect
for different students it's driving
learning above and beyond the
expectations and so that's where we see
this data down here and they bullet it
out students who completed 0 to 10
percent of their mission on average grew
as expected
these students barely used Khan Academy
so once again grew as expected this
means if you are an advanced student and
you're learning at a fairly quick pace
well you you grew as expected you grew
at that quick pace and if you are a
student who took a little bit more time
well you also grew as expected and so
when you didn't use Khan Academy just
what you would expect what happened but
then when you seizing when you
students who had significant usage of
Khan Academy students who completed 40%
of or more of their mission on average
grew 1.5 times more than their expected
growth in one year students who
completed 60% or more of their mission
grew an average eight 1.8 times their
expected growth so they almost had two
years of growth in one year and once
again I want to be very clear this is
this what we're plotting on the vertical
axis here this isn't just growth this is
average actual growth divided by target
growth so in a normal model if you just
look at the map data on a nationwide
basis whether a student is strong or
weak you if Khan Academy had no effect
you would expect you would expect just a
flat line right over here you would
expect everything everything here to be
just at one if Khan Academy was actually
less effective than whatever students
were doing before then you would say
well these students who are spending a
lot of time on Khan Academy then it
would be taking away from those other
things you'd see a downward slope but
over here we see that the students who
are actually using Khan Academy and
deeply and you could imagine any
large-scale studies like this you have
variation in the various fidelity to
which folks are using Khan Academy how
integrated is in the classroom but the
classrooms that are using it more deeply
more regularly are not just seeing
expected growth they're seeing they're
seeing one point eight times one point
they're seeing a significant multiple of
what you would expect their growth to be
so this is this is nearly two years of
growth in in one year of learning time
and that's once again this is sixty
percent plus so you know you can only
imagine what it would be if it's
complete 70 80 90 percent of the mission
or if it's used in an even deeper way in
different classrooms